[Musique]
métier de bouquinistes c'est d'abord
aimer les livres ce que j'ai fait
j'étais amateur avant des bouquinistes
suis comme livreur qui devient marchand
de vin et puis on aime la clientèle
parce qu'à un collectionneur vous
apporter quelque chose parce que nous
avions imaginé par ici bouquinistes non
non on entendu pas du tout non non non
je vois l'avenir sont meilleurs a
toujours des bouquinistes
[Musique]
et
oui
il
[Musique]
travailler sur les bateaux notamment la
pêche industrielle
et puis je suis parti ensuite à saint
malo et j'ai fait l'école nationale la
marche un moment donné je quitte à la
montagne ça fait deux ans j'ai fait le
choix de
d'exercer ce métier
je suis retourné
à ma passion
[Musique]
on avait dix huit emplacements vacants
on a lancé donc un grand appel à
candidature est là cette année ça a
vraiment en plus rencontré un engouement
particulier puisqu'on a eu 72
candidature faut savoir qu'en 2019 on en
avait eu 34
[Musique]
et
garder cette image très vivant de garder
ce lien garder c'est ce métier vivant
c'est très important pour nous et
d'ailleurs depuis les années et des
années nous ne faisons pas payer de
loyer sur cet emplacement serait une
exception
[Musique]